bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
ce qui m'a consacré à la rentrée
universitaire l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines inscrite dans
le projet paris-saclay vient de
réintégrer le classement de shanghai la
faculté compte désormais parmi les
établissements les plus prestigieux de
la planète
mais le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est aussi celui des grandes
écoles laissac un troisième sous encore
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
je vous propose tout de suite de
découvrir ce territoire d'excellence
et
il fait partie des 100 son université de
shanghai donc ça permet d'avoir un
meilleur cv il ya moins de monde
un geste et parisiens du coup on est
n'est plus suivie par les profs n'est
pas nouvelle l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines uvsq eu pour
les intimes jouit aujourd'hui d'une
solide réputation 2016 a vu son retour
parmi les élites dans le classement de
shanghai
du haut de ses 25 printemps l'université
yvelinoise fait partie du top 500 des
établissements les plus prestigieux de
la planète tels karvar dé cambridge son
ancrage au sein de l'initiative
d'excellence ou idex paris-saclay n'y
est pas étranger
l'idex réuni dix-huit établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
de la région ont reconnus pour leur
excellence scientifique et pédagogique
une équation capable d'engendrer des
projets scientifiques d'envergure en
osmose avec son environnement économique
une priorité pour l'université quand
didier guillemot a été élu le 10 mai ça
faisait partie de son projet indo
campagne de promouvoir le positionnement
de l'ue vs cul dans
le projet paris saclay pour défendre
pour être force de proposition au sein
de ce regroupement donc d'établissement
qui vont former paris saclay duvet
excuses aujourd'hui force de proposition
dans son projet pluridisciplinaire elle
propose plus de 200 formations et forme
chaque année près de 18000 étudiants
dont plus de deux mille six cent
soixante étudiants étrangers
plus de 90 % des élèves de l'ue vs qu
trouvent un emploi à l'issue de leur
formation
l'uvs escure représente une véritable
communauté avec six unités de formation
et de recherche
un observatoire des sciences de
l'univers deux iut plus d'un millier
d'enseignants et chercheurs une
fondation et une école d'ingénieurs une
école d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans
l'informatique la mécatronique et les
systèmes électroniques embarqués
nous avons la chance d'avoir un tissu
économique extrêmement dynamique qui
permet de fournir à la fois des places
pour nos stagiaires quand ils sont en
formation études donc type étudiants et
lorsque nous avons des apprentis pour
accueillir des apprentis
alors il ya des très grandes entreprises
très connu par exemple renault par
exemple thales qui accueille à la fête
des étudiants en informatique en
mécatronique en systèmes électroniques
embarqués
université aux écoles ces entreprises le
territoire permet une véritable synergie
pour faire de saint quentin en yvelines
la terre d'innovation tout elle se
revendique 16 1600 entreprises 145 mille
emplois un environnement propice à
l'épanouissement à l'apprentissage et à
l'entrepreneuriat le tout à 30 minutes
de la capitale vu ses résultats
maintenant nous pouvons rentrer dans le
processus de créer cette fameuse
université française qui s'appelle paris
saclay et qui regrouperait à peu près ce
qui est meilleur quand même en france au
niveau des grandes écoles soient
polytechnique supelec ou bien chaussée
avec deux c2 université paris sud est et
saint quentin et là on passerait de 20
milles à 60000 étudiants et là vous
auriez ce nouveau campus paris saclay
qui pourrait non seulement pas rentrer
dans les 500 premiers mais dans le top
20 des meilleures universités au monde
là vous auriez quasiment 10% de la
recherche française vous avez déjà en
gros trois prix nobel de physique qui
sont sortis si messi médaille fields est
pas moins de 5700 doctorante un projet
de longue haleine mais jean michel
fourgous rappelle que toutes les
conditions sont réunies pour faire de
paris saclay une réussite
vous avez un pôle d'excellence française
qui doit devenir demain je pense
la silicon valley française puisque je
vous rappelle que le et mighty niasse
méritait déjà classé cet espace de 51 à
saclay dans la les huit zones mondial
d'innovation dont vous avez toutes les
conditions et bien sûr pour réussir ce
pari
l'essai s'est très bien partie
indiscutablement licence master
laboratoire recherche universités a
atteint les objectifs qu'elle s'était
fixés
place désormais au bien-être au
bien-vivre l'agglomération met à
disposition une offre pléthorique de
logements étudiants
un souci en moins pour ces derniers la
nouvelle maison de l'étudiant s'inscrit
dans cette démarche les universités
c'est pas seulement un lieu où on étudie
ou fait de la recherche en c1 un lieu
aussi on se réalise et notamment
associativement et donc l'arrivée est ce
qu on a de nombreuses associations
étudiantes et ses associations disposer
de locaux répartis dans les différents
campus n'est pas d'un lieu de vie commun
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
manquait et donc avec l'ouverture de la
maison de l'étudiant qui s'appelle la
retape en début juillet et bien nous
leur offrons ce bio de vie service de la
vie étudiante santé logement vie
culturelle cohabite désormais avec les
associations pour plus d'interactions
c'est aussi en cette rentrée un
véritable guichet unique pour faciliter
les étudiants dans leurs démarches
maintenant les et les inscriptions des
étudiants sont complètement
dématérialisé donc ils peuvent faire ça
de chez eux
mais certains étudiants ou des soussous
donc ils peuvent venir à la haine dieu
et l'a à l'oeil nu sont guidés il ya des
postes informatiques
il ya des vacataires qui vont leur
expliquer comment s'inscrire une fois
qu'ils se seront inscrits on va d
orienter vers le service logement parce
qu'on sait que c'est vraiment une
priorité plus un étudiant
sert rapidement puis l'ims logement
rapidement et moins il décrochera donc
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose sur
lequel nous insistons lequel on est
extrêmement vigilant les étudiants
d'origine étrangère pourront aussi
obtenir leur carte de séjour sans se
déplacer à la préfecture les salles de
spectacles de sport et de réunions mises
à dispositions permettront qui c'est
l'émergence de projets associatifs
plusieurs animations coordonnée avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines sont organisées elles sont
ouvertes aux étudiants de l'ueh skull
mais aussi à ceux de l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny le bretonneux
automobile aéronautique transport guidé
les étudiants de l'estaca sont avant
tout des passionnés une passion source
de cohésion et de motivation les 1800
étudiants deviennent pas à l'estaca par
hasard c'est intéressant parce qu'on
touche à des stages à l'étranger à
pouvoir soutenir ses études même dans
d'autres universités
c'est une école postbac une des rares en
france à nous proposer une formation
aéronautique
dès le 2ème année donc très tôt c'est
une école qui me permettait
non seulement faire du ferroviaire mais
aussi si l'école qui est spécialisé dans
les transports et qui là dedans et la
mer dans le niveau de tous les
transports pour moi une vision globale
je m'attendais pas ce qui est autant de
garçons quand même encore pas raison
mais
non ça va on ressent pas le poids d'être
une fille en fait et ça nous permet
également aussi de mettre directement en
place nos connaissances d'ingénieurs
grâce à des projets qui sont donnés tout
au long du parcours scolaire et en plus
des différentes associations au coeur de
ce tacle l'estaca est la seule école
d'ingénieurs en france qui dispensent un
enseignement sont les quatre secteurs
des transports l'automobile
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire et le
spatial et ce dès l'après pac
on est vraiment dans une nouvelle
dynamique sur les transports c'est vrai
à tous les niveaux que ce soit sur
l'aspect des voitures alors en ce moment
c'est le mondial de l'automobile donc on
parle beaucoup de la voiture autonome
donc il ya vraiment une révolution qui
est en marche mais c'est vrai aussi dans
l'aéronautique on travaille beaucoup sur
en transformer les allemands pour qui
mme rouillé par exemple sont plus légers
beaucoup notre mission c'est de préparer
les ingénieurs a vraiment savoir
concevoir les transports de demain
les enseignants de l'estaca sont des
professionnels qui oeuvrent au sein des
entreprises du territoire
l'enseignement est ainsi adapté aux
besoins du terrain petites et grandes
entreprises sont de véritables
partenaires pour l'école si on a fait le
choix de venir s'installer à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est aussi parce
que on sait que c'est un territoire qui
est favorable pour nous parce qu'il ya
un certain nombre
grand groupe du domaine des transports
qui sont présents autre partenaire les
pôles de compétitivité les laboratoires
et les universités dans le cadre de la
recherche dont 32 universités à
l'étranger
un cursus jalonnée de succès 90 % des
étudiants de l'école sont embauchés dans
les deux mois qui suivent la remise de
leurs diplômes 61% d'entre eux occupent
une fonction ayant des liens à
l'international autre école de renommée
internationale troisième institut
international de l'image et du son basée
à trappes et à elancourt
c'est aujourd'hui le premier
établissement de formation supérieur
européen entièrement dédié aux
industries créatives à travers ses cinq
filières cinéma et audiovisuel
journalisme audiovisuel animations
numériques sont les techniques de
spectacle située au coeur de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines troisième permet de faire
découvrir aux saint quentinois les
possibilités d'insertion professionnelle
du secteur tout en les rendant
accessibles au plus grand nombre et les
étudiants ne s'y sont pas trompés le
matin même à disposition pour les
projets bon espace pour travailler les
autres
c'est parfait pour le journalisme
l'interaction entre toutes les filières
le cinéma l'art du spectacle et le fait
travailler tout ensemble ça apporte une
certaine diversité
il ya vraiment une cohésion de groupe et
ça ça me plaît cinq plateaux de tournage
dont un entièrement consacré à la
télévision une salle de rédaction 40
salles de cours des régies complète des
amphis depuis 20 ans troisième forme ses
étudiants de 15 nationalités différentes
aux métiers techniques du cinéma et de
l'audiovisuel
seule condition avoir le bac est passé
l'entretien face à un jury
ce qui nous intéressait pas vraiment
leurs résultats en termes académique
bien que les bulletins de notes et le
bac soit nécessaire mais c'est surtout
leur
leur créativité leur leur approche
artistique et puis leur culture
cinématographique autres dans le domaine
qui nous intéresse
troisième ce fait figure d'exception
près de 90% de ses élèves obtiennent un
emploi six mois à l'issue de leur
formation
un étudiant sur trois signe son premier
contrat avant même d'avoir fini son
stage vous un peu la fierté de l'école
et c'est ce qui fait que on arrive à
garder ce positionnement de premier
campus audiovisuel d'europe on met à
disposition des équipements dans le
cadre des formations pour toutes les
filières à la pointe de la technologie
de ce qui ce fait l'objectif étant de
former les étudiants sur le matériel
qu'ils retrouveront entreprises bien
implantées sur son territoire l'école
bénéficie d'un accès privilégié aux
équipements et structures culturelles de
l'agglomération
les étudiants accèdent gratuitement à
l'ensemble des médiathèques locales et
bénéficient de tarifs préférentiels dans
divers cinéma saint quentinois les
écoles du territoire ce vote à la pointe
des nouvelles technologies et des
besoins du 21e siècle comme l'institut
supérieur de l'environnement créé en
1993 les soeurs est pluridisciplinaire
science management et droit
le secteur est pourvoyeur des métiers
d'avenir avec une hausse de 36% ces sept
dernières années des perspectives
prometteuses dont le rythme devrait
s'accroître de 3 à 5% par an d'ici à
2020 de bac + 2 à bac + 5 lits et se
permet aux étudiants de devenir des
managers en france comme à
l'international et d'occuper des postes
de responsable développement durable
responsable qualité sécurité
environnement ou encore chef de projet
en éco entreprises d'entrants
saignements et pluridisciplinaire avec
d'une part des matières d'ingénierie
autour des sciences de l'environnement
beaucoup de droit et de droit de
l'environnement puisque pour travailler
dans les métiers de l'environnement il
faut avoir un solide bagage
réglementaire et puis un troisième socle
qui repose sur les matières de
management management classique et
management de l'environnement du début
durable entreprises collectivités
cabinet de conseil de multiples acteurs
économiques recrute ses nouveaux talents
aux compétences techniques et juridiques
spécifiques à l'environnement en plus
d'une capacité managériale
notre mission au sein de l'institut
superbe l'environnement c'est d'assurer
la meilleure employabilité possible de
nos diplômés avec la meilleure insertion
professionnelle possible et pour ce
faire on professionnalise au maximum nos
étudiants tout au long du cursus et
notamment en 4e et 5e année de l'école
les intervenants dans les différents
enseignements sont exclusivement des
professionnelles du secteur
l'institut peut également se targuer
d'un partenariat avec l'ue vs q les
enseignements dispensés ali et se sont
reconnus par l'université et permettent
d'obtenir une équivalence au sein de la
faculté
autre performance le taux d'insertion
professionnelle de ses étudiants
81 % trouvent un emploi dans les six
mois à l'issue de leur formation voire
quelques semaines seulement pour la
dernière promo à noter que les guichets
uniques de la maison de l'étudiant
permettra les dernières inscriptions
jusque fin octobre
à noter également qu'une nouvelle
résidence 247 logements pour étudiants
devraient voir le jour dans quelques
mois
d'ici là très belle rentrée
universitaire à toutes et à tous ciao